[Music]  what are you doing purse take it  mr. x5 a little bit I'm 2003 too bad  great  I'm a personal shopper here's very  high-profile take care she can't do  normal things so is a start I've nothing  better to do besides dressed Kira  waiting what are you waiting for my twin  brother died here it's from 95 days we  made this out  whoever died first with sin the other a  sign from the afterlife  is that always been  [Music]  love us you hear  I had a sign are you sure there was a  presence do you think Lewis is here I  don't know Kira I'm just gonna drop  these bags for you k hey Kira was  murdered  what were you doing at her please why  are you asking I'm lost I can't tell  whether or not I've gone crazy  [Music]  the mess I see you there isn't just me  I'm waiting my twin brother who died  here  we made this oath